>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> MARY ANN BROWN: Good
evening I'm Mary Ann Brown.
Welcome to Hill Center and to
our series, The Life of a Poet,
which is sponsored by the Library of
Congress and "The Washington Post."
And funded by the National
Capital Bank.
This is our fourth year of
presenting this program.
Our collaborators are, the
extraordinary moderator,
Ron Charles, editor of "The
Washington Post" Book World.
But, more importantly star of the
totally hit video, "Book Review."
If you haven't caught these online.
You absolutely must.
We've all been, they're hilarious.
And Ron has a new one out
reviewing Ian McEwan new book.
Our guest this evening
is poet, Terrance Hayes.
I'm going to go ahead and turn the
proceedings over to Rob Casper,
head of the Poetry and Literature
Center at the Library of Congress.
And before I hand the
mic over to Rob,
will you all please turn
off your mobile devices?
Thank you.
Please welcome Rob Casper.
[ Applause ]
>> ROBERT CASPER: Thank
you everybody.
Good to see you.
Thanks for coming out on
this rainy, yucky fall night.
The night that will be the first
of many nights like this, I'm sure.
Thanks to Marry Ann Brown for
helping inaugurate this series.
And thanks to Ben and everyone
here at the Hill Center
for letting us continue to bring
poets to chat with Ron Charles
and have the Ron Charles
poetry experience.
We're also really delighted to be
working with "The Washington Post"
and "The Washington
Post's Book World."
And most of all I'm always eager
to see what Ron's going to do.
I've gone to all 13 of these, right?
Thirteen of these events
and they're always a thrill
and it's always a fascinating
experience to see how Ron enters
into the work of these poets.
And has them read poems that they
probably haven't read in years.
Before I talk a little bit
about tonight's feature poet,
I just want to say a little bit
about the Poetry and
Literature Center.
Raise your hand how many people have
been to the Library of Congress.
Okay almost everybody.
Good, good, good.
The Poetry and Literary Center is
housed at the Library of Congress.
We've been there for
almost 80 years.
We host all sorts of poetry events.
We have an event on October 12th.
Our Asian American Literature Today
series with poets from Kundiman,
which is a great organization
out of New York.
Talk more about that and the
events that we have back in our.
[ Squeaking Sound ]
Is it this one?
Here. To find out more about those
events, you can visit our website,
it's www.loc.gov/potetry.
Now, I have the opportunity again
to introduce Terrance Hayes,
who's kicking off our fall season.
Terrance is the author of
five poetry collections,
most recently "How
to be Drawn" finalist
for both the National Book Award and
the National Critics Circle Award
and winner of the 2016 NAACP
Image Award for Poetry.
His other collections
include "Lighthead"
which received the National Book
Award that year, as well as "Wind
in the Box," "Hip Logic"
and "Muscular Music,"
winner of the Kate
Tufts Discovery Award.
Terrance's other honors
include a Whiting Writers Award,
a National Poetry Series
Selection and Fellowship
from the National Endowment
for the Arts and [inaudible].
In 2014 he was named the
recipient of a McArthur Fellowship.
And this year he was elected
to the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences.
I first met Terrance
in Pittsburg, in 1994,
which was almost half my life ago.
I have seen him grow and mature
as a poet, editor and teacher
in those years, but I've also
seen how constant he has been
in his dedication to
poems and poets.
How generous he is as a friend.
And his poems have always seemed
super charged by a signature mix
of invention and immediacy.
Myth making and memory
contended; playful, riffing,
and exploding personas; arguments of
the subline and a whole [inaudible].
He is as a lyricism of
life in [inaudible] though,
and takes a maximal approach in
contrast to, or even bolstered
by the rigor of its music.
For Terrance poetry
is as philosophically
and spiritually messy as
our spirits can allow for.
But from that is where it
offers us a sense of sureness.
A kind of a claim toward a space it
creates in the moment it creates it.
Be ready for all of the above in the
next 75 minutes and please join me
in welcoming Terrance
Hayes and Ron Charles.
[ Applause ]
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Happy to be here.
>> RON CHARLES: Really delighted.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: I'm not
going to read any poems.
>> RON CHARLES: Not
going to read any poems?
Okay we can talk about other things.
You know when you're a book
reviewer you become gradually inured
to the ritual humiliation
of standing next to giants,
or sitting next to giants.
And when they're certified
geniuses and they've been chosen
by "People Magazine" as one of
the sexiest men of the year.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: That's
not on my website [laughter].
>> RON CHARLES: That kind
of just seems almost
gratuitous and cruel [laughter].
Sorry about my voice, I hurt it
at the National Book
Festival screaming too much.
I want to start by
talking about your family.
What kind of family raised you?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Well, my mother
had me when she was about 16.
So, that meant we pretty
much grew up together.
>> RON CHARLES: Just you?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah,
well I have a brother.
She met my stepdad
when I was about 4.
So, he's been there and has
been there for a long time.
And he was a pretty creative dude.
He was in the military.
So, for many years we moved
and then eventually we sort
of stopped and he kept going.
But, he's retired now
and he's actually
in a new job working
as a prison guard.
Which is what my mother did.
She talked him into becoming a
prison guard after he retired
from the military,
and then she retired.
But yeah so they're you
know good, regular people.
When people ask me about their
influence what I say is they just
never discouraged me
which was great.
So, that they were curious and
they thought I was curious.
But no one ever said, don't
go to your room and write.
They did say, you know, why are
you always reading those books,
you know?
But there was never
anyone that made me feel
like it was something
I shouldn't be doing.
They also never made me feel
like I could make a living at it.
>> RON CHARLES: Not many do though.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, so there
was a kind of freedom in that too,
that I just thought oh well
this seems like something to do.
>> RON CHARLES: There's a
painful poem about your mother,
I wonder if you'd read,
called "Late."
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Okay, okay, yeah
I haven't read that one in a while.
"Late" from "Muscular Music."
This late no one is clean.
Not the bus's worn blue seats,
which keep themselves company.
Or the nurse in her
drowsy yellow uniform.
It's February and I
haven't spoken to my mother
since she told me to
take my shit and go.
Her face bare and serious as a wall.
The driver waves a gloved
hand at a passing bus;
slow and half empty like us.
Heads of the riders turned so
that I cannot say how they appear.
I was not born in this place.
But it is where I will try to live.
The miles between my mother and
here, stretching me into more
of a man than my father,
who'd drive from his
out of state job each weekend
to let her break his skin.
I'm glad I've left her sitting
in that house waiting
for her nails to grow.
Once she pulled a gun on me
because as she told the police
I was too big for a belt.
I called them, but they
did not take her away.
Later my father drove home and
said never put our business
in the street.
So, I shouldn't be telling you
this, how we sat in that house
like a family while a small
light beat the blinds.
My mother stubborn as a girl
who will not comb her hair.
There is no light beyond
the windows of this bus.
I am given my face, transparent
and bare on the glass.
After my father left that
night, the two of us sat apart
in the living room as the TV lit the
walls, the old white gown trembling
on her shoulders like
the sings of a moth.
I will say I did not
know she began to cry.
I was 18, trying to be a man.
It has taken me too
long to say this.
I am the same thing
I've always been.
A son. I do not know my mother.
But I want to touch her
now, as I did not then.
>> RON CHARLES: Lovely.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Thanks.
>> RON CHARLES: I shouldn't
be telling you this.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: You
want me to talk about that?
>> RON CHARLES: Yeah, what's
it like to write that sort
of intimate confessing of poetry.
What are the costs of
exposing your own feelings
and other people's feelings to that?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Well the
great thing about my mom,
because she does have a pretty
wild imagination, and you know,
in a different time, maybe like
20 years from now she would,
you know she would be me.
But she essentially said, you
know it's all your imagination,
you got such a good imagination.
So, that was like license
to say whatever.
So, I don't think she ever thinks
of my work as purely confessional,
she thinks that I'm
just making stuff up.
>> RON CHARLES: Do you think
you're ever confessional?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, yeah, but
I think an advantage of poetry is
that you can kind of come
in and out of metaphor
and in and out of shadow.
So, I can sort of be confessional
when people think I'm
not being confessional,
and you know dress things
when I don't want them
to be so confessional.
I mean what she said
about that poem is that,
well I never pointed it at you.
She was like [laughter].
I showed you the gun.
And said, I can see how that
would be good for drama.
But you know she actually
did have it out, so.
>> RON CHARLES: In
another poem, you said,
I knew later I'd be writing
these lines caught in that space
between personal and public.
What is that space between
personal and public?
How do you negotiate that?
How do you preserve that as a poet,
who wants to write
about his own life?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, yeah, well
I mean even the word that shows
up in that poem, transparency
that shows
up in the last poem is really
what I'm trying to achieve,
a certain kind of clarity, both
in the language and in feeling.
So, my sense is that if you can get
it right, if you can get the rhythm,
and the language, and
the sensibility right,
you can say whatever
you want to say.
Anything can be said if you
can say it right and sometimes
that means beautifully,
sometimes that means rawly.
Sometimes that means metaphorically.
So, whatever you think of as
right is what I'm always sort
of going for.
And when there's a failure
there, if someone says, you know,
if my mother, and they haven't
said it yet, nor my father,
if they are put off by it, that just
means that I haven't done it right.
>> RON CHARLES: You mean you haven't
transformed the experience enough
into art?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah.
>> RON CHARLES: It's just?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: A cousin of
mine, who also probably of all
of my family, my first cousin,
Pervis [assumed spelling] is
a person who's most interested
in my work.
He also is a prison guard.
But he said about het "Late"
poem, because he remembered it
because I went and
stayed with his mother.
>> RON CHARLES: After this ordeal.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: His
mother is my mother's sister.
Yeah, and he was like come on man.
You did not say, oh I'm a son.
You were so mad you wanted to
have her arrested [laugther].
And to him I said, yeah,
but that's not interesting
for the poem though, you know.
So, he had a better sense of
both the real-time response to it
and the sense of like
calling me on it in fact.
But I was like yeah, but you
know there has to be a turn.
So, and I said but that was better.
And I guess to say
that, when I wrote it,
this is me saying it
to him over beers.
Like when I wrote it, it was true.
It wasn't true until I said, I'm the
same thing I've always been, a son.
You know son before man.
I was a son before I was a man.
But for him, he wanted me to go
back to that, you know, that day
and me saying somebody call the
cops this woman, you can't do that,
which is what I was
saying, you can't do that.
>> RON CHARLES: I love
that poem the way it turns
after that terrible argument where
you feel your desperate love for her
as you sit there and
look back at that.
Even the boy with no father carries
in him the image of
his father you write.
Would you read the poem
called "The Same City?"
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure.
This is a, yeah.
>> RON CHARLES: The poem
about watching your father,
you call him your father, your
stepfather, trying to fix the car.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: That's right.
"Same City."
The rain falling on a
night in mid-December,
I pull to my father's engine
wondering how long I'll
remember this.
His car is dead.
He connects jumper
cables to his battery,
then to mine without looking
in at me and the child.
Water beads on the windshields,
the road sign, his thin blue coat.
I get out now, prove I can
stand with him in the cold,
but he told me to stay
with the infant.
I wrap her in the blanket, staring
for what seems like a long time
into her open, toothless
mouth, and I wish she was mine.
I feed her an orange
softened first in my mouth,
chewed gently until the
juice runs down my fingers
as I squeeze it into hers.
What could any of this matter to
another man passing on his way
to his family, his radio
deafening the sound of water
and breathing along all
the roads bound to his?
But to rescue a soul is as
close as anyone comes to God.
Think of Noah lifting a small
black bird from its nest.
Think of Joseph, raising
a son that wasn't his.
Let me begin again.
I want to be holy.
In rain, I pull to my father's
car with my girlfriend's infant.
She was pregnant when we met.
But we'd make love.
We'd take love below stars
and shingles while her
baby kicked between us.
Perhaps a man whose young child
bears his face, whose wife waits
as he drives home through
rain and darkness,
perhaps that man would
call me a fool.
So, what. There is one thing
I will remember all my life.
It is as small and holy
as the mouth of an infant.
It is speechless.
When his car would not stir,
my father climbed in beside us,
took the orange from my hand,
took the baby in his arms.
In 1974, this man met my mother for
the first time as I cried or slept
in the same city that
holds us tonight.
If you ever tell my story, say
that's the year I was born.
>> RON CHARLES: That's got to
be the best poem ever written
about stepfathers.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: You know
when I read it I would usually
begin by saying stepfathers.
I mean the poems are
always chaining,
so I was like I knew you
saw it, so I can't edit it,
but usually I'll start in the
first half and say my stepfather
and then say father, but.
>> RON CHARLES: You
are the stepfather
in that poem, or about to be.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: No, it was
just a girl who had a kid.
>> RON CHARLES: Well you
could be you're in that role.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, sure.
No, that right.
That's right I'm taking
care of somebody else's kid.
>> RON CHARLES: And then you mention
these other historically famous
stepfathers, Joseph.
You say in that poem,
to rescue a sole is
as close as anyone comes to God.
Did James Hayes save you?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, yeah,
you know he was artistic,
and tender, and tough.
Yeah, I mean we were fine
until I decided to look
for my own dad in my thirties.
Because he was just like, you know
his mom had him when she was 14
in Florida, so he certainly
saw a relationship.
But you know he was,
again, very cool.
He was like a great soldier, which
I'm always still thinking about.
Like that's not my personality.
I'm much more like
transparent and talkative.
He's tender, but not a
big talker, you know.
Sort of classic dad I guess.
But certainly, I learned
a lot from him, man,
you know he was there from four.
I mean that's sort of the idea
of the poem, like if he shows
up at four years old I mean
he's pretty much my dad.
>> RON CHARLES: And the contrast
between the working on the car
and squeezing an orange
into an infant's mouth.
So, so brilliant.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: So, you know,
sometimes the poems just come
to you, but you know if I
only waited for those kinds
of moments I would write
a poem every five years.
But that poem is, I mean the thing
that I think I must have
adjusted was something
about the main scene
is totally accurate.
I'm trying, you know
I can't remember now
because it was just one of a girl.
But she did have the kid and
somehow we were still dating.
And so, I was essentially
babysitting for her.
You know, and she had tried
to convince me at some point,
this is the stuff that
doesn't make it
into the poem, that
it might be my kid.
And I kind of knew it
wasn't, but I had been
with her before she got pregnant
and so I was like you know what,
I'll just you know ride it
out and see what happens.
But essentially his car
did breakdown one night
when I was watching the baby so
you know I went and I felt it then,
which happens, but I mean the
writers in the room you know
if you live every day, there's
probably five days of the course
of your life where you say, oh that
was a poem, like that whole day.
Like somebody just sent me.
And I do think you know a lot
of being a poet is
listening for those moments.
So, if you listen with your
heart they're always there.
But at that time, it
was like, oh wow,
look a poem just dropped in my lap.
My dad just called me to, you know.
So, I just pretty much.
>> RON CHARLES: And you
wrote it into the poem.
In the poem, you say
you'll remember this.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, and then the second half of like
trying to get at the meaning of it,
let me begin again, is again
where the imagination or empathy,
or metaphor starts
to kind of set in.
But and I guess I say that because
I could just as easily make it
up is what I would tell you.
Sometimes I make up
everything in a poem and people,
because I've read something like
that, they think it's all true.
Which I'm like sure you
can think it's all true.
>> RON CHARLES: Yeah, right.
You say in another poem, papa
why can't I be a rascal too?
Were you rascally or not really?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: No,
no I was pretty square.
I liked to draw and read.
And my brother, my dad's full son,
my brother was also pretty good.
We were pretty good kids.
You know.
>> RON CHARLES: Did poetry seem
like a likely career for you?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: No, no.
>> RON CHARLES: Did
you know any poets?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: No,
but I was a visual artist.
So, and that was strange
enough for them.
So, no definitely nobody
was thinking about.
>> RON CHARLES: What did they
think of your interest in poetry?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: They
were fine once I started
like making a living at it.
>> RON CHARLES: Yeah, but that
was you know, relatively late.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, sure.
>> RON CHARLES: Not
when you were in?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: As I said,
I mean the best thing they did
and this is really a
testament to my father.
Because my mother is
maybe more like I am.
Like you usually know
exactly what she's thinking,
you know what I mean?
She's a terrible, as I
am, terrible poker player.
But my dad is pretty, so if my
dad had an opinion about it,
he wouldn't have said it.
But had he said something
I would have listened.
You know. So, they just were
like, well that's what he's doing.
>> RON CHARLES: You said, when
I was getting ready to graduate,
I wondered if I would go
play basketball overseas
or get an MFA in painting.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Right.
>> RON CHARLES: Those
doesn't seem like the usual,
you know binary choices a guy makes.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: I wish I had
gone over for a little while now.
But now I'm too old to do it.
>> RON CHARLES: In your first
collection, "Muscular Music,"
you've got a poem called
"What I Am."
Would you read that.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure.
Sure. That's like the opening poem.
That's right there,
it's "Muscular Music?"
>> RON CHARLES: Oh,
we're in the wrong book.
Number three.
In my lap.
Sorry. Always in your other purse.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: I'm
going to say upfront,
because Rob will know
what I'm talking about.
This poem was, I had read
some James Tate poetry.
It changed it enough that I don't
have like after James Tate in it.
But I always think of this as a
poem that would not have happened
without the poet James Tate,
who passed away recently.
He wouldn't know it even if
he'd look at it, he wouldn't be
like oh he's writing like me,
but that's where it comes from.
"What I am."
Fred Sanford's on at
12 and I'm standing
in the express lane cash
only about to buy Head
and Shoulders the white people
shampoo, no one knows what I am.
My name could be Lamont.
George Clinton wears colors like
Toucan Sam, the Froot Loop pelican.
Follow your nose, he says.
But I have no nose, no mouth,
so you tell me what's good,
what's god, what's funky.
When I stop by McDonalds
for a cheeseburger,
no one suspects what I am.
I smile at Ronald's poster,
perpetual grin behind the
pissed-off, fly-girl cashier I love.
Where are my goddamn fries?
Ain't I American?
I never say, niggaz in my poems.
My ancestors didn't emigrate.
Why would anyone leave
their native land?
I'm thinking about
shooting some hoop later on.
I'll dunk on every
one of those niggaz.
They have no idea what I am.
I might be the next Jordan god.
They don't know if Toni
Morrison is a woman or a man.
Michael Jackson is the
biggest name in showbiz.
Mamma se Mamma sa mamma ku sa,
sang the Bushmen in Africa.
I'll buy a dime bag after
the game, me and Jody.
He says, Fuck them white
people at work, man.
He was an All-American
in high school.
He's cool, but he don't
know what I am, and so what.
Fred Sanford's on in a few and I got
the dandruff-free Head and Shoulders
of white people and a cheeseburger
belly and a "Thriller" CD
and Nike high tops and slavery's
dead and the TV's my daddy.
You big Dummy!
Fred tells Lamont [laughter].
>> RON CHARLES: That
is a crazy poem.
I love them, what I think it's
about is the way these
different forces are trying
to define you and none of them are.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, sure.
>> RON CHARLES: None of them works.
The white culture is
trying to define you
in very you know classic
racists ways.
And black culture's trying
to define you too in ways
that you fine uncomfortable.
Is that close?
>> TERRANCE HAYES:
That's right, the speaker.
That's right.
The speaker.
So, I mean you can tell the
poems that are all like all here,
and then the poems that are here.
So, that, I mean there's
heart in it, but that's just
like a meditation almost.
You know, so the truest things
is that I did have a friend
who was an all-American
guard, named Jody, you know
but he would have never said that
to me, but whenever I see it,
I think oh yeah, old
Jody, Jody Patten.
>> RON CHARLES: In another
poem, you confess, I'm not cool.
I keep the real me
tucked beneath a wig.
I'm a small American frog.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: And the other
part, which is the truest part
of that poem, I'm sweating
even as I tell you this,
where's my handkerchief, yeah.
I was already going to pat
my brow before you read it.
>> RON CHARLES: But that
little frog kind of remind me
of Emily Dickinson's
modest talk about herself.
The frog and the admiring
bog, I'm nobody.
You've got another frog too, in
a poem called, "The Segregate."
Remember that little frog?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I do.
>> RON CHARLES: It's a
relatively brief poem.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Okay.
"Segregate."
On the first morning of school
there is a young tree frog waiting
patiently at the front gate.
Since this means there will be no
classes for the rest of the day,
the children dump their
school gear in their lockers
and hustle to the windows to stare.
The girls are eager to transform
him with a kiss, the boys eager
to see him on the basketball court.
But their principal greets him
with a get the hell out of here.
A security guard fetches
the teargas.
Some of the old teachers crowd in
the doorway like befuddled geese.
You belong in our swamps,
not our schools they rage.
But clearly the cool blooded
amphibian American does not agree.
>> RON CHARLES: Where did
you come up with that?
This metaphor of African-American
as amphibian American?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Well, you know
that's the kind of formal thing
that interests me, so that
poem is playing with the form,
I mead up a bunch of anagram poems.
And so, the in lines come
from words in side segregate.
So, gate, and rage, and
tear and tear and so,
some who once I started
kind of working
on the poem, that's what emerged.
So, and I do think of, I mean I used
to have a little Kermit
the Frog doll.
So, have I told y'all
that story before.
There's another sad story.
My mom, actually I don't tell it
because it's such a terrible story,
but so I'm always thinking
about Kermit the Frog,
but my Avatar would probably
be a turtle, but the frog comes
up because it's a family thing.
Now I got to tell you.
>> RON CHARLES: I don't know
where to go with any of that.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: I know.
I did, I had a Kermit the Frog.
>> RON CHARLES: Turtle might
be the last animal we think
of in relation to you.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure.
Well it's got a little shell so it
can always go in when it needs to.
And then inside his shell he's
got music and posters and.
>> RON CHARLES: But
you're this giant.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: A
piano in the corner.
>> RON CHARLES: You're
this dramatic guy
that commands the whole room what
do you have to do with a turtle?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: That's why a
shell is good to have [laughter].
So. I had a little frog.
And, see, this, I actually have
never told this story even if,
I know if Rob doesn't know it.
But I'm going to tell you the full
because it's like the late story,
the full arc of it, I
am more sympathetic.
But when I was young I had a
little frog from like you know 4
to let's say 6 or 7
and it went with me.
I put it in the tub and all
of my family knew about it.
But one day I broke
my mother's vase.
She had like a little flower vase
and I guess I was playing
and I broke it.
And in her rage, she took
the frog and she cut it up.
And I think that's when I
became a poet [laughter].
So, of course she's
always regretted it.
And in my family; my brother and
my father it's what we always.
As I said, she's you know talkative
and energetic and anytime we want
to win an argument we
say, but you know you cut
up Terrance's frog [laughter].
And then we're done.
So, clearly I was wounded.
And you know she regretted
it later, but the turn on it,
if I were to ever write
about it in a poem is,
and I just realized this I want
to say like in the last year.
I was just doing math and I
was like I think I was like 6
or 7 which means my
mom was like 22 or 23.
And now that I'm older I
totally could believe that a 22
or 23-year-old could cut
up the frog of a kid.
But at the time, I just for
a long time I just saw it
as my mother, you know.
You know mothers don't quite age.
They're just always mothers.
But, when I look back on it I
thought, well it doesn't excuse it,
but it does to me change it a little
bit to think about how young she was
when she did such a reckless thing.
So, but I don't, you know that's
why I haven't written about it.
I mean to go into my process
like I could never write about it
without having some
shape to it, some.
So, because to just
be mad is a flat line.
But to think about like
coming around the bend.
So, I still don't know if that's
enough to make we write about it.
But it's a big story in my family
because it was a pretty huge thing.
>> RON CHARLES: This
is a longer poem,
called "Self Portrait Vision" based
on the, it involves a painting.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Right, I haven't
read this one in a long time.
>> RON CHARLES: Is that
the right painting?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah,
that's right, that's Winslow.
>> RON CHARLES: You have a few
clues here, of course my black
and white drawing means
nothing to you,
you can describe the painting
maybe before you start.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, sure.
Well you know, it's just I
mean you probably know this.
>> RON CHARLES: These people
will know the painting.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: And guy's
sort of on his back on the boat.
And the boat is tilted and
there's a storm around him.
I mean there's not that many
images, certainly of like solitary,
black figures in the history
of American paintings.
So, I think that was one of
the things that drew me to it.
It was just such an
unusual thing to see.
Do you want me to, oh you want
me to read this part of it, okay?
>> RON CHARLES: You can
read the whole poem.
Too long?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah,
it's a little long.
>> RON CHARLES: Oh, yeah I
mean this part of the, sorry.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: So,
is this the last part?
This part is called, yeah,
"Self Portrait/Vision."
The man tells nothing.
He carries nothing.
He is covered by almost
nothing but strokes of light.
He knows what I would like to know.
How a white man came to paint
beauty into a black man's face.
And why he left sharks slashing
the water beneath his feet?
But he does say, what is that, but
he does not say, I am not his kin.
I, who was born of a people
who never learned to swim.
People who had no word for the
blur line that divides each day.
This is why he does not look my way.
So, we pine for his never-minding
scowl, Homer at his easel in 1899
as the harbor filled with
saltwater and lightning.
And me, these last months I've spent
staring at the painting as rain
and wind walk hand and
hand into the city.
Did he know it would storm that day?
This mariner or fishmonger?
This refugee backtracking
through the middle passage,
kingdom of the un-salvaged,
the hushed fathoms
fleeing home to find home?
I can pretend, but I
do not know enough.
Or I know as much as
Homer could have known
of what a drowned man feels.
The flood of last wishes
and the hours beginning
to darken and drift off course.
As a child, I'd sneak to
watch teenagers' roughneck
in the neighborhood pool.
One night as I knelt at the
deep end stroking the water,
a white boy shoved me in.
Can you remember the womb?
How, in the moments before birth,
the lines were washed from the map
that told the route you'd come?
Perhaps downing feels that way.
The one who saved me had dark skin.
He left me on my side gasping
for air like a startled fish.
After my father removed my soaked
shirt and sneakers, he got his belt.
He beat me until welts rose.
Like new muscles along
my arms and legs.
Like brushstrokes along my back.
I learned living requires
a kind of discipline;
a reverence for the law of gravity.
But I have wanted,
as I want when I look
at the paining, to unhouse my body.
I have wanted the kind of grace
God gives only to the drowned;
the boundlessness of a man
conjured out of gossip and time.
Out of theories of demise; of a man
who will not be the
painter's handsome one.
Who does not ask for help
but awaits the tide's eulogy.
>> RON CHARLES: Okay.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, it's been
a while since I looked at that one.
>> RON CHARLES: It's
a brilliant poem.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Thank you.
Thank you.
>> RON CHARLES: The way it
moves, from that painting
to your own much more
harmless experience.
Because you could have
drowned I assume.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, sure.
Yeah, that's right.
And that was true.
>> RON CHARLES: And the way
the speaker could have drowned.
And the way it involves
the middle passage
and then your own experience
with racism.
It's just a lot of things
going on in a poem like that.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah,
you know Ta-Nehisi,
I don't think Ta-Nehisi Coates
who you all should know,
I think it's in a beautiful
struggle.
And I feel like, I don't know
if we've ever actually talked
about this, but there's a scene
in that book where he goes out
and is almost hurt, or almost
injured and I think it has something
to do with cops and
then he comes home,
he's reprimanded by his father.
So, the thing that I remember
from that experience is
that I almost drowned.
That it's actually a
Nigerian guy saved me
and when I went home I was punished.
You know my father did beat me.
And sort of making the parallel
between like I'm beating
you because you almost died.
I'm beating you because you didn't
take care enough in the world.
>> RON CHARLES: And
it strengthens you,
as you say those welts
rise like muscles.
>> TERRANCE HAYES:
Right, right, yeah.
I mean and you know I
don't think I would,
I wouldn't necessarily
reprimand my son that way.
I know Ta-Nehisi wouldn't
reprimand his son that way.
But certainly, I think for
the time, it made a kind
of sense, but I still was shocked.
I mean I was shocked enough as
I think I said earlier to have
to work it out in a poem,
to find some shape to it.
I mean if I was only again angry
at you know how he treated me
after a life and death experience,
I wouldn't have written it
so I think I understood
it enough to write it.
But I don't know if I was going
there before the painting.
I think maybe thinking about the
painting helped me get there.
>> RON CHARLES: Right you
write a lot of about paintings.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, yeah.
>> RON CHARLES: You paint yourself.
>> TERRANCE HAYES:
That's right, yeah.
>> RON CHARLES: It was one
of your career choices.
>> TERRANCE HAYES:
I still mess around.
>> RON CHARLES: You painted some
of the covers of your books.
>> TERRANCE HAYES:
Yeah, all of them.
>> RON CHARLES: They're lovely.
One's been replaced with
a photograph of you.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah,
that's right, it was initially.
I didn't want them to, I asked
can I put a drawing on it, but.
>> RON CHARLES: How do
you decide when you want
to express something should
it be a painting or a poem?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: I just express.
I just, it can be both I
think is sort of what I think.
I try not to differentiate.
I mean, you know again, this
sounds like a boast but it's not,
because I can't play the piano.
But I would say just as, it
would be like anybody picking
up an instrument they can't play,
but just saying let's see
what kind of sounds come out.
So, that is probably the best way
to understand writing versus art.
I do, at this hour have more
control, or more facility as a poet
than I do as a painter, I think.
I don't think that was always true.
But it's true now.
Certainly, more as you know a
piano player or prose writer even.
But the idea is just you know
to not get too caught
up in what you're doing.
But just to do it.
>> RON CHARLES: You say here, he
knows what I would like to know,
how a white man came to pain
beauty into a black man's face.
That goes right to the heart
of the discussion we've
been having this week
about cultural appropriations.
Who can write about black people,
who can write bout Mexican people.
Can people of different
races write about,
you've heard the argument,
it's been going around.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Only
well is what I would say.
You can write whatever you want,
you just have to write it well.
>> RON CHARLES: Flush
that out of it.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: That's why
when you write about a tree,
you don't have to write
it that well.
Because people know what trees
are, and they're not political.
So, you just, when I think about
this you know dig to people
who only write landscape poems, but
I do think when you start getting
into kind of cultural
questions there are more risks.
And it just depends
on your sensibility.
I mean I like risk for
myself and I admire risk
when other people are doing it.
And you know it does require
a little bit of generosity,
especially when people are not doing
it well and if you're a teacher,
you know you encounter poorly
written risky things all the time.
So, I think you still, you know,
you still encourage
them to take that risk.
So, I would never say no.
In fact, there's a side note.
I did a reading, the last
reading I did before this one was,
I'll make this quick.
I read for a bunch
of students at NYU
and I decided to only read new work.
So, one of the poems
I read was an eraser
of the first 20 minutes
of "Delirious."
So, I don't know if you all remember
the first 20 minutes of "Delirious"
where Eddy Murphy comes out.
He talks for a good little
bit about gay people,
but he ain't saying gay people.
So, an eraser means I'm just
highlighting all of that.
So, there's a moment where I said
you know pussy like seven times,
because that's what he did.
So, I'm saying that and then you
know faggot and there's others,
I mean I selected other
stuff to give it shape,
but I'm really highlighting
what he's doing
and after 20 minutes he talks
about his family so we're done.
So, I read that and there
was I guess a transgender guy
in the audience and so he
raised his hand then and he was
like why did you read that?
>> RON CHARLES: He was
offended, you got the impression.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Well, he
told me later that he was,
but at the time he just raised
his hand and then I said,
well you know I want to know
if people heard what I heard,
because my sense of Eddie Murphy
in that segment, and actually most
of Eddie Murphy is like
it's a kind of homophobia
that becomes homoerotic and so
I was like I want to isolate
that so we can see
it and it's just him.
So, everybody else in the
audience was like yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then he didn't say anything,
but then I saw him on the street
about three days later and
he came up to me and said,
I just didn't think
it was a good poem.
I think you were really
highlighting what was problematic
in Eddie Murphy.
And I was like yeah.
But at the end after that whole
conversation what I said to him is
that but can a writer ever
really come up to another writer
and say don't write that?
>> RON CHARLES: People do say that.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: I just don't
think; I think that's a really.
>> RON CHARLES: What do you know?
People say to write writers what do
you know about the black experience.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Right, right.
Again, I say well so
as I said to him,
I was like well you might be right,
because I only read new stuff.
It was an experiment.
I did want to hear it and I hear
you but what I'm saying to you
as a young writer, talking
to me is that don't you know
that that's a really slippery slope
to like police what creativity is.
>> RON CHARLES: Then we're
all stuck in our own.
We're all stuck writing
our own biography.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, but again,
I didn't say that he was wrong
and I thought about it and he was
like well you should write more.
I was like I might,
I might keep going.
But I just, at the end
of the day if you go
to the point that you're making.
You can actually write
whatever you want to write.
It could be bad or good.
But I just don't, I'm certainly not.
I wouldn't be that as a teacher,
and just in general in the world,
I've never looked a person
and said you can't write that.
I could say you can write it better.
But I would never say that's
not your place to write it.
So, that's generally I mean
at the other end of that,
you know teaching a workshop
in West Palm Beach and it was
like retired old white people
and the conversation became,
and I covered this space.
I tried to create a space where
people would say what they want
to say and they're like well
what are we going to write
about we just old white
people [laughter].
But if you were a white person
who live in a white town
with white cars, and white
fences, and white house.
That's an interesting poem though.
Like, a poem about just
all whiteness I think
that's interesting.
>> RON CHARLES: Right, and
you can use your imagination.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Imagine
that, yeah, if you imagine it.
So, I'm saying like you know
that's sort of your work.
Like if it was easy, that'd
be like writing about trees.
Like, there's your challenge to do
the thing you're not supposed to do
and do it in a way
that's transformative.
So, that's what I think.
>> RON CHARLES: Okay.
I agree, totally agree.
Lionel Shriver kicked us off with
a series of essays and a speech
after she her own recent
novel was criticized
for cultural appropriation.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, sure yeah.
I mean those things exist,
but they are most problematic
when the work, the results are bad.
But I think the results can be.
Again, I mean that's Homer,
like I think that that's
it is a good painting.
And I'm free to think
about like wow,
I can't believe he painted this.
He did paint it you
know what I mean, so.
You know, yeah I would
never say across the board
that there's things you should
not be able to do as a writer.
>> RON CHARLES: Because
it's not you.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, yeah.
>> RON CHARLES: Yes.
Let's talk about race.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: That's
what we were [laugther].
>> RON CHARLES: So
fantastically sharp critiques
of racism in America.
And yeah, I also sense some
discomfort with the liberal clichs
and tropes of race in America too.
I wonder if you'd read a
poem called "Woofer" is
that how you pronounce it?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah it's
like a speaker, or a barker too
but it's like a sub-woofer.
>> RON CHARLES: Oh, okay,
yeah I know that word.
Yeah.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: "Woofer" what
I consider the African-American.
So, there are things.
I guess this is the place to say it.
So, buried in this poem is howl.
That's also like I'm
not howling I'm woofing.
So, you hear in the
beginning if you know howl.
But again, it's not in the notes and
it's just me, like burying stuff.
It's like the frog.
Like, no one would ever
know but when I see it,
I'm seeing something else
maybe than what you're hearing.
But now you might hear it.
When I consider the much-discussed
dilemma of the African America,
I think not of the diasporic middle
passing, unchained, juke, jock,
and jiving sons and daughters
of what sleek dashikied poets
and tether fisted Nationalists
commonly call Mother Africa,
but of the African
girl, who was the child
of a black-skinned Ghanaian
beauty and Jewish-American,
globetrotting ethnomusicologist.
I forgot all my father's warnings
about meeting women at bus stops
which is the way he met my mother.
When I met her waiting for
the rush hour bus in October
because I have always been a sucker
for deep blue denim and Afros
and because she spoke so
slowly when she asked the time.
I wrote my number in the back
of the book of poems I had
and said something like "You can
return it when I see you again"
which has to be one of my top two
or three best pickup lines ever.
If you have ever gotten lucky
on a first date you can
guess what followed.
Her smile twizzling above a
tight black V-neck sweater,
chatter on my velvet
couch and then the two
of us wearing nothing but shoes.
When I think of African-American
rituals of love,
I think not of young, made-up unwed
mothers who seek warmth in the arms
of any brother with arms because
they never knew their fathers,
though that could describe
my mother.
But of that girl and
me in the basement
of her father's four story Victorian
making love among the fresh blood
and axe and chicken feathers left
after the Thanksgiving slaughter,
executed by a 3-D witchdoctor
houseguest.
His face was starred
by tribal markings
and her ruddy American poppa
while drums drummed upstairs
from his hi-fi woofers because
that's the closest I've ever come
to anything remotely ritualistic
or African, for that matter.
We were quiet enough to hear
their chatter between the drums
and the scraping of their chairs at
the table above us and the footsteps
of anyone approaching
the basement door
and it made our business sweeter,
though I'll admit I wondered
if I'd be cursed for making
love under her father's nose
or if the witchdoctor would
sense us and then cast a spell.
I have been cursed, broken hearted,
stunned, frightened and bewildered,
but when I consider the
African-American I think not
of the tek nines.
This is the howl.
I think not of the tek nines of
my generation deployed by madness,
or that we were assigned some lousy
fate when God prescribed job titles
at the beginning of time.
Or that we were too dumb
to run the other way
when we saw the wide
white sails of the ships
since given the absurd
history of the world,
everyone is a descendant of slaves.
Which makes me wonder if outrunning
your captors is not the real meaning
of Race.
I think of the girl's bark
colored, bi-continental nipples
when I consider the
African-American.
I think of a string of people
connected one to another
and including the two of us
there in the basement linked
by a hyphen filled with blood;
linked by a blood-filled baton
in one great historical
relay [laugther].
That's great.
I keep feeling I need to
give it to you every time.
>> RON CHARLES: I'll take it.
I'll take it.
Again, and again in that
poem, you reject the sort
of generalized statements about
African Americans in favor
of your own person experience.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure [laughter].
>> RON CHARLES: Is it a poem
about being the subject of a sort
of sociological description
that's not comfortable,
it doesn't really describe you.
Doesn't describe your
own experience, is that?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: I will
say what I try to say
to like my students especially
at the beginning of the year
in a workshop which is,
I mean identity is fine,
but personality is just
so much more interesting.
So, I think of poems
trying to get at something
like personality not identity.
Because if I just do identity, I am
playing into like received notions.
But personality can include that.
I mean I am black.
I am from the south, I am tall,
like all of that stuff is true.
But there's also other things, like
my mamma cut my Kermit the Frog up.
Like is that identity
or is that personality?
So, like in all those
gestures before.
I mean this is something that
I'm, you know I an articulate now,
I couldn't have articulated
it when I wrote that poem.
But I do think mostly I'm
trying to do something with a,
particularize I guess what
we think of as identity.
>> RON CHARLES: Yes.
Yes. And in a poem called
"Roots" you write my parents
would have had me believe
that there was no such thing as
race there in the wild backyard.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, I
mean they just didn't really.
I mean this was the eighties.
This was like after integration so
I think they thought we didn't need
to have that conversation.
Maybe they still kind of.
>> RON CHARLES: You
were just who you were.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah.
Yeah. And again, that's
like am I a poet or not.
Not speaking about it
had some advantages,
and there were obviously
disadvantages too.
Which is to say if I'm
linking things together,
like not quite understanding why my
father would like you know beat me
because a white boy
pushed me in the water.
Not quite understanding
until I'm older.
And so, I mean my problem is that I
would try to talk to my kid at six
and seven about what
the implications were
and probably not be right.
So, I can't say that he was wrong to
day, you know you'll figure it out.
But that certainly was how
they dealt generally with race.
It just wasn't, maybe it looked too
abstract and too complicated except
for in you know life and death
situations to really talk about.
>> RON CHARLES: Then, "The New
Yorker" comes along they say this
about you.
"Racial trauma is everywhere
in Hayes' work.
Instantiated by his personal ghosts.
An absent father, a mother
who worked as a prison guard,
an array of family
troubles and damage."
It sounds like you just
barely escaped with your life.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Like everybody
is what I think when I see that.
Again, this is my personality.
>> RON CHARLES: Spends
their life like running
through a ghetto being shot at.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah,
but this is a thing
about you know an 88-year-old
woman who lived in a white house
with a white dog and a white car.
Like yeah, that sounds terrible.
But I bet you could
make a poem out of that.
You know what I mean.
So, I hear that, I've never
thought of it as good or bad.
I mean in a way we don't think
of our lives as good or bad.
We think of it as you know a series
of peaks and valleys, ups and downs.
So, I see that.
And I think it's true, but it's
not, it wouldn't be the way
that I would I think about my life,
it would be a little too simple.
But certainly, there's drama.
I mean I like drama, so.
>> RON CHARLES: Your
life was not a series
of horrible racial
heartaches, though.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: No, no, no.
Or if they were nobody told me, so.
>> RON CHARLES: I want you
to read a poem called "Pine."
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Okay.
So, it sounds like you
gravitate towards the real kind
of confessional autobiographical
stuff, or maybe that's all I write.
I have been told that.
>> RON CHARLES: You know one of the
issues with this series is that some
of your more excremental
poems have to be seen.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, sure, sure.
This is true.
>> RON CHARLES: Like
you've got some great.
Like the poem that's
arranged like a crime report.
>> TERRANCE HAYES:
Right, right, right.
>> RON CHARLES: It doesn't
play when you read it.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah,
I've maybe read it out once.
>> RON CHARLES: You have to
show it to them to see it.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: But these
are I just keep picking up poems
and saying, yeah that happened.
Because this poem sounds
unbelievable.
But this too is fairly accurate.
>> RON CHARLES: And this
is based on an experience
with you and one of your buddies.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: That's right.
That's right.
So, the epigraph is, is
this one long sentence?
>> RON CHARLES: I didn't
notice that.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah,
it might be I have to see.
I do like a long sentence.
>> RON CHARLES: It's very narrative.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Right, right.
So, the epigraph is Larry
Levis I still had two friends,
but they were trees.
We were just talking about
trees, you got me reading "Pine."
Okay. "Pine."
In the dark we loved
someone's far-fetched bounty
from a truck's black cab
and it was a bad idea.
In the bedevilment, better
than the rocks we'd thrown
at the dogs behind each low fence.
The branches we'd torn from
samplings barley rooted
to the fields, Boomie and I, our
heads in a swivel of trouble.
Our two tongues sweeping
distractions, a few hours' worth
of wrong turns behind us, we were
restless and miles from home.
Dark boys roaming in the dark.
Okay, there's a period.
We found a pick-up truck
unlocked outside a small hotel
and in its cab trash bags fat with
clothing and housewares, a toaster
and vacuum waiting to be used again
by someone checked in for the night.
Maybe a runaway wife,
reversing her dreams.
A streak of red wine
sleeping on her tongue,
while elsewhere her
husband was in the dark,
because he didn't know
yet she was gone.
She was gone.
For no good reason, we took
the bags from the truck
and plopped them below the pine
trees, which like very thing
in the dark belonged to us.
And to anyone approaching our
laughter must have sounded
like the laughter of crows.
Those birds that leave
everything beneath them,
trampled and broken open.
Those birds dark enough to
bury themselves in the dark.
But we were not crows and we were
not quiet until it was too late.
I was thrown against the tree as
if I weighed less than a shadow.
A hand clutched the back of my
neck as if it wasn't a neck.
Cuffed later inside
the breakproof glass,
I watched the policeman
nuzzling everything we touched.
Slithering, their faces calculating
absolutes while the trash bags
shimmered in a fiasco of light.
When I looked up, I saw Boomie
nearly twenty feet high in the arms
of a pine almost nothing visible,
but his white shirt
and white shorts.
I could feel him feeling as
sorry for me as I felt for him.
And I said nothing.
Think of what the tree might
have said If it could speak.
Hold me for a moment
then, let me go.
Something an unhappy housewife
might say to her husband
on the last night of their marriage.
Or a boy to policemen when
he's locked in a squad car.
I heard a voice between
their voices issuing numbers,
codes and uninterpretable verses.
Addresses in a bewildered city.
I was to be taken somewhere
and given a name more bona fide
and afflicted, I was to be shot
through the knee and then shot
through the jaw, Boomie
must have thought.
Even when the scene was clear.
He must have remained.
It must have been like clinging
to the massive leg of God.
If the leg of God is
covered in bark.
If prayer is like waiting for the
darkness beneath you to change
into something else,
if it's like waiting
in the darkness to be changed.
Yeah, that's true [laughter].
The wildest day.
Yeah he was up there man.
He was like, you know pine trees
don't have branches on them.
So, yeah I barely read these
poems so it's sort of like I'm
in a bar remembering an
antidote or something, but.
How did he climb?
That was like climbing
like a telephone pole.
And he just held on to it.
>> RON CHARLES: But the first
time you mention him up there
in a tree, I mean, right?
I mean you think the worst.
>> TERRANCE HAYES:
So, you know because.
>> RON CHARLES: White police.
A black guy up in a tree.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Right yeah, yeah.
>> RON CHARLES: It's a shock.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: And one
locked in the car, locked in it.
But you know because it's
new I can still see the lines
that have alike a little bit more
heat on it or, so that's kind
of nice about reading it.
Of all the things that I said, like
I could feel him feeling as sorry
for me as I felt for him.
That was what I remembered, that's
really what I took from the night,
looking up at, I could see him,
I didn't know where he had gone.
But because I was bent
over and handcuffed.
But when I looked up I saw him.
And then the question was am I
going to say anything, should I say?
Because I was so tall they
figured we were grownups.
But had they seen him they
would have figured we were kids,
you know because they didn't believe
me when I was like I've 15, I'm 15.
So, anyway, but I just
thought I'm not.
But then I just thought about as
hard as it would be, I mean as long
as it took them to kind of take in
the scene he held onto the tree.
So, I didn't say anything and
then they took me to the place
that we were staying and
when his mom came out she was
like where is he and
of course her mind went
to the most terrible things.
What did you do to my son,
these two guys were together
and he's not here.
And they were like
what are you talking
about this was the only kid
there and he wasn't back yet.
It had been a minute and so they
were confused and then I was
like he's up the tree,
y'all, he was up the tree.
And then the cops were
looking at me like what,
what are you talking about.
So, they let me out, you
know, a lot of fanfare.
And then he did really hold
on for as long as he could
and eventually he did come home.
And he was scraped up and you
know he had been wearing shorts.
He looked like he had you
know been hit by a tree.
So, when I think about that like
what was better to be clinging
onto that tree above the scene or to
be down beneath it experiencing it.
So anyway, so that's the line I hear
when I see it because that was my,
I felt bad for him and I
know he felt bad for me,
like who has it worse here?
Like that.
>> RON CHARLES: Definitely you.
I mean it's hard not to read a
poem like that in the context
of the year we just
described, right.
And seeing so many people
shot down by police,
sometimes without any
apparent provocation.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure.
Sure. Yeah, yeah.
But a dead man can still have pity.
I mean I think we know
that form the outside.
So, I didn't know what
was going to happen.
I didn't know if I was going to
be, I talked them into taking me
to this place, back to the
house, but I just kept thinking
about in the horror of like are they
going to see me, am I going to fall.
So, I still think about how
frightened he must have been,
how still thinking more
about what that would look
like for him than it was for me.
>> RON CHARLES: You
weren't that afraid?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Well
he was a good distraction.
I might have been afraid
until I saw him up the tree,
you know like what's
happening, what the?
You know so that is, that always
comes back to me more than my fear.
So, I did tell the cops my mom was
a prison guard and I was trying
to sweet talk my way out of it.
>> RON CHARLES: Okay let's take a
little break just a few minutes just
to stand up and shake our legs out
>> TERRANCE HAYES:
Y'all are so patient.
>> RON CHARLES: These
are great poems.
I want to look a little further back
in the issue of race and history.
You do a lot of deconstructing
of American history,
it reminded me a little bit
about the way Natasha
Trethewey does it looking back
at myths and figures.
I think yours are a little funnier
maybe, a little [inaudible].
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sometimes.
>> RON CHARLES: Sometimes.
A little playful.
You've got a poem called the
"Black Confederate Ghost."
This is just fantastic.
If you'd read that poem for us.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure.
Sure.
>> RON CHARLES: It's
in your latest book.
Where am I.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: It's
in there somewhere.
Yes. "The Black Confederate
Ghost Story."
Attention African-American
apparitions hung,
burned or drowned before
anyone alive was born,
please make a mortifying midnight
appearance before the handyman
standing on my porch
this morning with a beard
as wild as Walt Whitman's.
Except he is the anti-Whitman,
this white man
with confederate pins littering
his denim cap and jacket.
And by "mortify" dear ghosts, I
mean scare the snot out of him.
I wish I were as tolerant
as Walt Whitman waltzing
across the battlefield like a
song covering a cry of distress,
but I want to be a storm
covering a confederate parade.
The handyman's insistence
that there were brigades
of black confederates is
as oxymoronic as terms like
"civil war," "free slave."
It is the opposite of history.
Goodbye plantations
doused in Sherman's fire
and homely lonesome women
weeping over blue and gray bodies.
Goodbye colored ghosts.
You could have headed north
if there was a south to flee.
In Louisiana north still begins
with Mississippi, as far as I know.
East is Alabama, west is Texas,
and here is this fool
telling me there were blacks
who fought to preserve slavery.
Goodbye slavery.
Hello black accomplices
and accomplished blacks.
Hello Robert E. Lee bobble head doll
on the handyman's dashboard
whistling Dixie
across our post racial country.
Last night I watched several hours
of television and saw no blacks.
NASDAQ. NASCAR.
Nadda Black.
I wish there were more ghost stories
about lynched negroes haunting
the mobs that lynched them.
Do I believe no one among us
was alive between 1861 and 1865?
I do and I don't.
We all have to go somewhere and
we are probably already there.
I know only one ghost story
featuring a brother in Carrolton,
Alabama, dragged to the
center of town in a storm
for some crime he didn't commit.
As he was hung lightning
struck a window
on the courthouse he's
been haunting ever since.
Attention apparitions, this
is a solicitation very much
like a prayer.
Your presence is requested tonight
when this man is polishing his
civil war relics and singing
"Good Ol' Rebel Soldier" to himself.
Hello sliding chairs.
Hello vicious whispering shadows.
I'm a reasonable man, but I
want to be as inexplicable
as something hanging a
dozen feet in the air.
So, the last time I
read this poem, I think,
or I think it must have been the
last time, maybe I've read it once
since then, was in like Phoenix,
Arizona and then we had like Q&A
and a brother came to the mic and he
said, well you know blacks did fight
for the confederacy and I was like,
yeah but that's neither here
nor there, did they fight
to preserve slavery, you know.
So, but it is a similar thing to
what I was saying to the student
which is to say, but it's you
know, it's so much more nuance.
Like if you work in those extremes,
like you can't write that poem
because there were blacks who
fought for the confederate.
And I would say you just missed
the whole point, you miss the point
of what I'm trying to
you know to communicate.
But you know that happens
where people are doing
weird fact checking,
and I was like do truth checking
don't do fact checking so.
>> RON CHARLES: That is a
really rye poem though isn't it.
I mean to call up all the
lynched ghosts of the past
to come haunt this Confederate.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, sure.
>> RON CHARLES: As he polishes
his old metals and gets ready
for his next civil war re-enactment.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Well,
you know this is one
that is pretty much imagine.
Because a dude, and I have seen
them, but it was actually my wife.
He came over to do something, to
fix something when I wasn't there
and then when I came
back, she told me.
And I was like you know
I've got to write that poem.
>> RON CHARLES: The little
bobble head in the car.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Right.
So, I made, I just made
myself interact with him.
Because otherwise I would
have had to found him
and like do something to him, so.
>> RON CHARLES: It is amazing
to me that we still have
to have this argument about the
confederate flag, about history.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, sure.
>> RON CHARLES: It
just takes so long.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Right yeah, yeah.
I mean I don't know if I'm, I find
it interesting is what I would say.
I don't know if I think that
there's a corner to turn.
So, obviously, he gets a
poem because he's interesting
and I mean everything in the poem.
But I also think, well you know
this is whatever his reality is,
let me see if I can
engage this a little bit.
However, crazy and backward it is.
>> RON CHARLES: And subjective
of a certain amount of satire.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, yeah, yeah.
That's how I'm getting my revenge.
>> RON CHARLES: Right, yeah.
It seems like a very
political poem to me.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, yeah.
>> RON CHARLES: Does poetry, I
mean should poetry be political.
Can it be political.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, sometimes.
I don't think a poem
is ever one thing.
Like a metaphor is never one thing.
But I think of myself as an
engaged citizen in the world.
I think of myself with a
deep interest of politics.
You know. Yeah, I mean I can't
get enough of CNN you know.
But it's also I mean, if I talk
about myself part of
it is spectacle.
Like there is something
inherently spectacular
about how people become politicians
and how people themselves
are political in a way
that you know he's a spectacle.
He's got confederate
flag, and he really did.
You know his truck is all of that.
So, like that is political,
but it's political because it's
like wow you know like
what is that all about.
So if you think of politics in
that way, like something to do
with the way people sort of what
people believe their belief system,
it's very difficult
to not be political.
>> RON CHARLES: In one of your poems
you refer to our hysterical country.
You mean funny there.
You mean.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Hysteria, and
how else are you going to deal
with the sab I mean it
has to be hysterical.
So, it has to be satire, because
otherwise it's too tragic.
>> RON CHARLES: There's
another, I didn't notice it,
but it also has a Halloween
effect with the
"Elegies with Zombies for Life."
That's a very political poem.
Read that for us.
It has to do with a political
issue that cuts both ways.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure.
Sure.
>> RON CHARLES: Where is that?
>> TERRANCE HAYES:
It's in the same book.
It's in "How to be Drawn."
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I wouldn't know,
as again writing
about trees, people up trees.
I wouldn't know how to not really be
political because I just think it's,
I mean a person can chose to deny
their sense of the political,
but can one not be political,
I don't think that that's true.
I think that you can decide not to.
>> RON CHARLES: But a poem that
has a strong political thing
that we all got would be
a bad poem, wouldn't it?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, generally.
Again.
>> RON CHARLES: Argument.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Generally.
You know but those kinds of things
make me feel like, oh I should try
to do that you know what I
mean, like is see as a kind
of a challenge more
than as an absolute
when we think about like what.
So, there are poems and
usually persona poems like the
"Blue Baraka" is somewhere here
and that was me trying to be
like well Baraka, is like
you know he wants you
to know exactly how political he is.
And so, I was like well I'll just
take on, anyway that's separate.
So, this is "Elegies
with Zombies for life."
The trouble with living
like thinking is feeling
is it's not really living.
So to me that's a political
statement.
That is me thinking about
since politics is so rooted
in really thinking, you know
kind of like a sense of morality.
Like is morality feeling
or is morality thinking
you know what I mean,
like but if that's how you're
living, are you really living.
Anyway. Sorry.
The trouble with living
like thinking is feeling,
is it's not really living.
I think, for example, these are
good times save the mornings I want
to say "Shame on you motherfuckers"
to the motherfuckers trafficking
homemade posters of death
on the corner between
my home and the cemetery
that holds among its dead the bones
of the great pianist Mary Lou
Williams, the mother of jazz.
Music was her child
Because she had no child.
For Mother's Day my
children and I took my wife
to visit Mary Lou's headstone
May 8, 1910-May 28th, 1981.
We found it unmoored and
untended, Unattended on a hillside.
People who say don't live in
the past Don't have a real sense
of the past, would
you agree with that?
Life is not about what you learn,
really, but what you remember.
I was in a diner once when
I saw a young mother passed
out with her face in her plate.
I have been thinking about
the horrified Expression
of her little boy as a
waiter approached the booth.
Near me a lady in a business suit
sighed, "For that kind of woman,
abortion should be free."
Think about the theory That crime
rates have declined since Roe
vs wade versus the theory
that sexually transmitted
diseases have increased.
Think about identity versus
ideology versus idiocy,
the Center for Bio-Ethical
Reform versus the Centers
for the Bio-Unethically Formed.
The Center for Life and Hope versus
the Center for Death and Despair.
Because thinking is feeling, I
think about death All the time.
The food under my nails,
the nails underfoot,
the skullish sockets
packed with dirt.
Maybe the soul is tethered to
the body like an embryo even
when the body is no longer alive.
Maybe zombies have taken over.
Are you for the humans for life, the
families for life, the armed forces
for life, or are you
for something else.
Because thinking is feeling there
are thousands of compartments
and pigeon holes in my braid.
There are polemics and porn
flicks and utopian blueprints,
court briefs, sketches, graphs,
philosophical theories like
"Cruelty is a form of laziness," but
there is only one version of death.
It takes work to imagine the
ineffable, which I think is the word
for something that
can't be eff'd up.
I think the sanctimonious are
worse than people who hate music.
Would you agree with that?
At this very moment, they
are fighting about the order
of things you should value.
God, family, country, no.
Love, justice, money.
I can no longer grasp
the logic of conflicts.
In the prolife versus
prochoice debate for instance,
it's the versus that's
of interest to me.
Remember Fred Williamson saying
to the friend who became his enemy
at the end of "Bucktown," I don't
want to kill you I just want
to beat the hell out of you.
I love the lovely restraint in that.
Cruelty is pretty damn
lazy, actually.
It takes more effort to earn
someone's love than it does
to punch someone in the face.
May you be punched in the face,
may you weep until your nose is fat
and crumpled as the hood
of a child's raincoat.
That's my curse for
the self-righteous.
That's the "Thug Life for Life"
in me, a former self versus a self
who wants to change, Cassius Clay
Versus Muhammad Ali, who said,
"A man who views the world
The same at fifty as he did
at twenty has wasted
thirty years of his life."
The trouble with thinking thinking
is feeling is sometimes There is
no feeling.
Twenty years ago, I would not have
believed my unborn child would still
be here pushing a cry out of me.
>> RON CHARLES: Now that seems
like a great political poem.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, sure.
>> RON CHARLES: Because
it's an attack on this sort
of reductive political arguments
that dominate our lives.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure.
Well, again as I'm reading,
of course I don't read al the time
there's all these moments where I'm
like well I know exactly
what that's about.
You know so Bucktown, there's this
movie, that has Pam Grier in it
that nobody knows,
and Fred Williamson.
There is a scene where the
guy, they go into the town
and the town has been taken
over by some white racist
mobsters they had cops actually
and this dude has a bar I think
but he was like in Vietnam
and he had some old Black Panther
friends so he calls all them in.
this is Fred Williamson he
calls all these guys he's
like I'm going to get you guys.
Call my boys in we're going
to fix this right away.
So, he calls them, they come.
But once they beat up the white
guys, this is what's so great.
They decide they want
to stay in power.
So, his friend have suddenly
just taken the place.
So, after all of this, they come
into a moment and now they're
about to the final scene and Fred
Williamson says to this friend,
I don't want to kill you.
Which is what you'd
do in the normal kind
of like black [inaudible] thing
you come and you kill everybody.
But since they're friends he
says, 'I don't want to kill you,
I just want to beat
the hell out of you.'
And I think like yeah,
that's actually a pretty
ripe political sentiment.
Like you have empathy
for your enemies even
when they weren't your
former best friend.
But you know you confront these
people who have done things.
That have hurt you or hurt
others who are really fucked up
and essentially, you're
like, you know I just need
to beat the hell out of you.
I'm not going to kill you though.
So, anyway I thought oh
that's never put in movies.
So, that, I was already
working on the poem
and there's things around it.
But when I'm reading it and I see
that I suddenly had a whole flash
of Pam Grier in the movie
and loving that moment.
You know it's a terrible movie,
but I don't want to kill you,
I just want to beat
the hell out of you.
That just seems so
right for a T-shirt.
>> RON CHARLES: You
have an avocado poem.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yes.
>> RON CHARLES: With
my tabs right there.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: It's in
"Lighthead" wherever that is.
>> RON CHARLES: Here.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: I just.
I don't. You know I think
about the difference
between poems and poets and poetry.
I don't even think, I'll say people
first, I don't actually think I
like people, but I like
persons you know what I mean.
Like people always a problem.
People do really dumb things.
And that same thing about poetry.
Like I think I try to focus on
poems and not too much on poetry.
Which is to say it is always
the very particular things
that excite me in poems.
I don't even know what made me say
that, I think it's just something
about his poem that
made me say that.
>> RON CHARLES: The poem
you're about to read?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, I mean I think that's, yeah,
that's a comment on the political.
The particular inside the political.
>> RON CHARLES: You talk about
form in one of your poems
about how you, you know that line?
Can I just pull it up here?
I care less and less about
the shapes of shapes.
Because forms change and nothing
is more durable than feeling.
That seems to be reflective
of all the different kinds
of forms you're experimenting with.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure.
Sure. Shapes are good, but
they are not as permanent.
You can think about
translation that way too,
like when you're a translator,
you're trying to think of a sense
of feeling more than even
a sense of like precision,
or a sense of form, I think often.
Sometime you could
get both, but yeah,
that would be generally
how I think of the world.
You know the most enduring
thing would be feeling even more
than thinking.
>> RON CHARLES: "Avocado."
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Okay.
"Avocado."
In 1971, drunk on the sweet,
sweet juice of revolution,
a crew of us marched into the
president's office with a list
of demands, the black man tells
us at the February luncheon,
and I'm pretending I
haven't heard this one before
as I eye black tortillas on a
red plate beside a big green bowl
of guacamole made from the
whipped, battered remains
of several harmless former avocados.
If abolitionists had a flag it
would no doubt feature the avocado,
also known as the alligator
pear, for obvious reasons.
Number one, reparations, enough gold
to fill each of our women's wombs.
Gold to nurse our warriors waiting
to enter this world
with bright fists.
That's what we told them, the
man says, and I'm thinking
if the money colored flesh of the
avocado, high in monosaturates.
Its oil content is
second only to olives.
I am looking at Yoyo's caterpillar
locks dangle over her ear.
I dare you to find a lovelier
black woman from Cincinnati,
where the North touches the South.
Three, we wanted more
boulevards named
for the Reverend Dr.
Martin Luther King,
Jr. An airport Named
for Sojourner Truth.
The roots of the avocado
tree can raise pavement,
so it's not too crazy to imagine
the fruit as a symbol of revolt
on the abolitionist flag.
We are all one kind of
abolitionist or another, no doubt.
And we are like the avocado too
with its inedible ruby colored seed
that can actually sprout from inside
when the fruit is over mature,
causing internal molds
and breakdown.
Demand number twenty-one, a
Harriet Tubman statue on the mall.
Brother man is weeping now and
walking wet tissue to the trash can
and saying, Harriet Tubman
was a walking shadow,
or he is saying Harriet Tubman
walked in shadows, or, to many,
Harriet Tubman was a shadow.
To walk in.
And the meaning is pureed flesh
with lime juice minced
garlic, and chili powder.
It is salt, and pepper Harriet
Tubman tossed over her shoulder
to trouble the bloodhounds.
Many isolated avocado trees fail
to fruit from lack of pollination.
Goddam, ain't you hungry?
I whisper to Yoyo, and she puts a
finger to my lips to distract me.
Say, baby, wasn't that you
waking me up last night
to say you'd had a dream where I
was a big luscious man Size avocado?
Someone's belly is growling.
We weren't going to be colored.
We weren't going to
be negro the man says.
And I'm thinking every
time I hear this story,
it's the one telling the
story that's the hero.
Hush now, Harriet Tubman probably
said near down, pointing a finger,
black enough to be her pistol
barrel toward the future,
or pointing a pistol barrel
black enough to be her finger,
at the mouth of some
starved stammering slave
and then lifting her head
to listen for something
that no one but her could hear.
She did have that dream too.
I think that's what
started that one.
An actual dream where
I was an avocado.
>> RON CHARLES: Now, they did
not read this poem at the opening
of the African American
Museum last week, why?
>> TERRANCE HAYES:
It's too complicated,
it's too personal maybe.
>> RON CHARLES: Yeah,
it's more than that.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, why?
There's a few things in it
I mean the question like,
who's getting made fun of
in it I think is part of it.
>> RON CHARLES: I mean someone
like John Lewis is standing
up there telling about the
great stories the great heroes
and you're like, you know.
Basically, coming on to this
woman and thinking about avocados.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: But
you know that line is,
I was just thinking
about inflecting.
Like every time I hear this story.
You know every time
I hear this story,
it's the one telling the
story that's the hero.
Or every time I hear that story is
the one telling the story that's the
hero [laughter].
>> RON CHARLES: Yes.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: You know so,
and both those things
are true, you know.
>> RON CHARLES: But this poem
does sort of undercut, doesn't it?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Well when she's.
>> RON CHARLES: The sanctity of what
he's describing with a little humor.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, I
would say that's the thing
about like the either or dynamic.
Versus like that, what I just
did with that inflection,
like I'm trying to do both.
>> RON CHARLES: Maybe the young
man is the one being made fun of.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah,
the star stammering slave.
Like the young man who keeps talking
about the avocado, is where she's
like shut up man let's
get out of here.
So, that's the sort of parallel
that's happening at the end
of the poem without saying it like
overtly, but like who is the fool
in the room is really one
of the questions to kind of,
the question with soft
answers around it I guess.
Like, maybe it's this person,
maybe it's that person.
Yeah, but that I think again, that's
interesting to me around politics,
as opposed to like the hard, and
maybe that's what I was thinking
about when I was bringing
up like the particular
versus a general sense of
politics, which is like politics
in that moment where no matter
what, it could have been MLK,
but if you're hungry, you're hungry
you know, like okay how am I going
to talk about both these things.
>> RON CHARLES: Yeah, it's
brilliant it really is.
It really is brilliant.
Let's end with "How to Draw
an Invisible Man," shall we.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Okay.
Sure, sure.
That's one sentence.
>> RON CHARLES: We're playing
off of one of the great.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: It's in
your lap, the "How to Draw."
>> RON CHARLES: The great
American writers and one
of the great American images,
metaphors in American literature.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, sure, sure.
"How to Be Drawn."
Yeah, I mean I don't know.
I mean you know what I would
say is that like, certainly I,
I'm still just on the politics.
So, attitude is everything.
Race, masculinity gender
marriage, southerners.
I just sort of feel like that is
like what I eat, it's what I live.
So, I never feel like I'm working
super hard to be that in poems.
I say that because so
certainly when I see poems,
something that I keep saying,
and I'm looking at this
because like what am
I most excited about?
I just said it that
it's one sentence.
So, all the other stuff I just
know that I try to be conscious,
I try to be transparent, I try to
be honest, I try to be empathetic
and then I say if I'm
trying to be that,
sometimes the poems clarify that.
But I don't write the poems as a way
to like necessarily even advocate
for it, because I feel like
that's what the real life is for.
You know what I mean.
>> RON CHARLES: If you were
advocating the poem would be dead,
right?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Right, right.
So, instead I say, can I
write one long sentence.
I mean there's other stuff going
on, but essentially like a kind
of technical question
because I think,
you know everything I've done before
I sat down, will come to bear.
>> RON CHARLES: Yeah,
but a dramatically technical
poem would not be of interest
to us if that's all it was.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: I know it.
But I'm sort of talking about
like, my, what excites me
or my concerns around the poem.
They're always the same as others,
even if the poem is advocating
for you know a better world and
a better life, I would say well
that starts first in the poet.
Like if the poet is
trying to like chase
that where you hope the
poem will show that.
What that means then as
a poet, and I mean again,
I'm sort of talking as a teacher.
So, what you're saying to
the student is like well,
think about something else.
Like, say that you are trying
to be transparent regardless
of what your political
affiliation is.
And instead work on a
long sentence and hope
that that process will reveal what
you really think about the world.
And then trust that even
if it's a slanted view,
or a wrong view, trust that.
Focus on something else
will illuminate that.
>> RON CHARLES: I can see all
that, but what makes your poetry
so spectacular seems to me,
are those sudden shifts
of theme and image.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Sure, sure.
I mean it's true, I mean
I'm not unaware of it.
I guess I'm just sort of
saying, like what comes first,
or where my pleasure is in it.
And so, it's not that I like have
made a large political statements
so much as like wow I got
that all in one sentence.
All right anyway, "How to
Draw and Invisible Man."
And then when Ralph
Ellison's corpse burst open,
I discovered his body had been
hoarding all these years a luscious
slush, a sludge of arterial
words, the raw and unsaid pages
with their plots and propositions,
with their arcs of intention
and babbling, with their
mumbling streams and false starts
and their love and misanthropic
thrusts, tendons of syntax unraveled
from his bones and intestinal
cavities, the froth of singing,
stinging, stinking ink, reams of
script fraught with the demons,
demagogues and demigods
of democracy,
demographics of vague landscapes,
passages describing
muddy river bottoms
and elaborate protagonists crawling
through a foliage greener than money
in America before America thought
to release anyone from its dream,
the water-logged monologues one
who is unseen speaks burst suddenly
from Ralph Ellison's
body and because I mean
to live transparently,
I am here, bear with me,
describing the contents the
fictions envisioned by Emerson
and immigrants, the
dogmas, aboriginal progeny,
scholastic recriminations, dementia,
jubilee, hubris in Ralph Ellison,
Duke Ellington's shadow, a
paragraph on the feathered headdress
of Marcus Garvey, some of it was
pornography, some of it alluded
to Negros who believe educating
black kids means teaching them
to help white people
feel comfortable,
some of it outlined the perks of
invisibility, how we are obliged
to eschew the zoo, the farm
animals, it had something to do
with captivity, flayed in the
clinical light the notes printed
on the underside of his flesh were
reversed but readable mirrored
in the metal of the
medical table and I wanted
to print it all properly in
a posthumous book in the name
of prosperity and proof the genius
we believed he'd wasted had been
waiting all these years for a
simple death sentence to break free.
>> RON CHARLES: Do you
feel yourself writing
in the shadow of Ralph Ellison?
>> TERRANCE HAYES: So, here's like,
the dream would be to write Baldwin,
but I sort of go at Baldwin
with so much reverence he becomes
a harder figure to personify.
But like Baraka, and so when I
say like misanthropic thrust,
because you know, I don't know
how many people know this,
but you know Ralph Ellison
was quite an asshole.
Did you know that about
Ralph Ellison?
>> RON CHARLES: I actually
met him once.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah,
yeah I don't know what he
was like when you met him.
Was he an asshole?
>> RON CHARLES: Very old.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Oh, okay.
Maybe he was nicer at that point.
But I never met him,
but that's the word,
even Tony Morrison
said it so [laughter].
And so that became
interesting to me.
In addition to the great dilemma
which is in the poem which is
like where is the rest of the work?
>> RON CHARLES: Right.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: You know?
>> RON CHARLES: Old decade, after
decade waiting for that next book.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: So, I do,
I mean I love "The Invisible
Man" it's still a favorite book
of mine, but he becomes subject.
Again, I'm still just talking
about walking about because
of those tensions, the
tension between like an artist
who doesn't necessarily, I don't
want to say live up to his potential
because he only had to
write "The Invisible Man."
His essays are good too.
But does it?
>> RON CHARLES: Grow,
progress, move.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah,
doesn't make you know
as much as he might have made.
And an artist who, is, you know a
misanthrope for whatever reason.
I mean I think we wall
have that in us.
But those things kind
of come together
around like imagine what it
would be like if you know
if you were like the coroner.
>> RON CHARLES: To open up his
body and get at those words.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Yeah, so I'm
saying yes he is deeply interesting
to me, even if I would put in my
like you know universe
of writers, Baldwin.
But the sad thing is that
because Baldwin is above him,
Baldwin might not necessarily
get a poem.
You know what I mean, because
like he's unimpeachable.
You know what I mean until
something, one day I wake up
and I be like what was up with that
and then maybe he'll get something.
But, so yeah he's interesting
but if he was only reference,
you know it might not be the same.
>> RON CHARLES: Right, yeah.
This is the most fascinating
evening thank you so much.
>> TERRANCE HAYES: Thanks, man.
[ Applause ]
>> ROBERT CASPER: There,
there we go.
There are books of
Terrance's in the back,
outside please grab them come back
in and have Terrance sign the books.
>> RON CHARLES: Buy the books.
>> ROBERT CASPER: Grab them
as in pay money for them.
Also, next year we have in
February Brenda Shaughnessy coming.
And in April I believe Dana Levin.
We hope you come back
to Life of a Poet.
And check out all the wonderful
programs here at the Hill Center.
If you need to learn
how to use a knife,
you can learn how to use a knife.
You need to learn how to write poems
you can learn how to write a poem.
So, until then, and on the 12th of
October, as I said we have an event
at 4 o'clock, check out website
and we hope to see you there.
Thanks so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.